[Music]
tell me about this room why does
everyone go the experiencie so in there
you are getting to experience in the
best restaurants us Portland
Nash San Francisco and with this new
blue Delta SkyMiles credit card from
American Express you earn two miles for
every dollar that you spend any rest on
the US so we're showing you here that
there's a lot of food to be eaten and a
lot of mild severe makes me happy and I
don't make you happy so yeah dining our
way for our next getaway doesn't really
get better than that
okay it's only about the exact moment
that the Sheikh Haitian hashtag came to
light
shake asian hashtag change away please
just for my love of travel and wanting
to share my experiences and i'm super
excited to be able to partner American
Express and Delta Airlines of a new
credit card the blue Delta SkyMiles
credit card is giving users the ability
to earn miles while they eat so
literally every dollar that you spend at
a restaurant in the US you earn two
miles for your next getaway Jake
Mitchell is the ultimate Globetrotter
and now the Pretty Little Liars star
wants to help other travel lovers take
off on their next adventure I know that
you're actually gonna be giving away a
prize to new travelers can you tell me
about that to celebrate the launch of
the new Delta SkyMiles credit card we
are actually looking a really special
contest where a winner and three of
their friends can win a trip to
Nashville so a super fun-filled food
excursions the three other friends where
they get to have round-trip Delta plays
get to stay at an Airbnb and a lot more
and I mean anybody can really end
if you go on delta MX lucam JS
partnership comes at the perfect time
shall likely need to jet back to LA to
catch your former co-star Sasha Pieterse
a-- on Dancing with the Stars I will be
more than happy to be sitting front row
screaming the loudest for Sasha I'm your
protector for rule then more information
head to Delta Amex lucam
[Music]
you